the amazing thing about web 1.0 right
was all of a sudden everything was
available online information was
accessible you could get it on your own
terms when you wanted it it was
permanent and instantaneous at the same
time so the notion that there was only
one way to deliver information and to
and to access information that blown up
and space and time in in real this is
not theory we're not talking you know
Einstein theory space and time
fundamentally changed and it was great
it was freeing it was liberating and but
it was but it was still limited in its
dimensionality it was basically
two-dimensional web 2.0 made it three
dimension because all of a sudden you
add this component of interactivity and
the customer is in charge and the
customer drives and open systems beat
closed systems is basically
participatory interactive open
communication dialogue real-time
personal participation in the life of
information creation sharing evaluation
boom so you took something that exploded
time space and add another dimension
which is you're stepping inside of it
it's almost I mean I don't want to be
too I don't know that much about physics
but what I know about physics is when
you go into quantum physics the game
changes because the participant
determines the outcome of the experiment
that's web 2.0 okay it's no longer
changing space-time it's reinventing
reality so that the participant
determines the outcome of the experiment
and that blew the game open even more
what happens with 3.0 4.0 I am waiting
to see stay as my friend Keith Yamashita
used to say watch this space